the government is looking into big tech
essentially whether companies like
Facebook Google and Apple are too big is
Apple too big no I don't think so I
think that with but with sighs I think
scrutiny is fair I think we should be
scrutinized but if you look at our any
kind of measure about app is Apple of
monopoly or not I don't think anybody
reasonable is going to come to the
conclusion that Apple's a monopoly our
share is much more modest we don't have
a dominant position in any market you
know our share of smart phones in the
u.s. is typically in the high 30s or so
mid 30s on PCs it's lower than that and
so on and so forth and so on so you're
saying you're not a monopoly we are not
a monopoly but Elizabeth Warren who's
campaigning for president says Apple
should break up its App Store and other
parts of its business
well I strongly disagree with that I
think some people would argue if you are
selling a good then you can't have a
product that it competes with that good
and I think that's part of what is being
argued there but that's an argument nor
that takes you down the path that
Walmart shouldn't be stocking a
alternative or house brand and so this
is decades of US law hearing but I think
scrutiny is good and will will be will
tell our story to anybody that we need
to or that wants to hear it